okay four people joining this meeting we
are doing a review of some often
language functionality and somebody
needs to meet themselves there um the UM
the the topic we're talking about today
is progress indicators we could call it
progress about progress okay so let's
talk about boy there's a lot of levels
of opening to do here um okay right
right so Julia did you have any specific
questions up here before we go to grid
panel or did we just want them all there
in case just a recap yeah just a recap
okay so right so these are sort of you
know the sort of the main kinds you see
and then there are a few sort of more
specialized ones you see for you know
whatever case so so one of the questions
here I mean the goal is to have an
increasing number of kind of you know my
point of view and maybe people disagree
my point of view is whenever we can so
long as the thing is not going to leave
its detritus in the notebook and so long
as it's not going to cause the notebook
to jump around like crazy showing
progress is always a good thing does
anybody disagree with that claim as long
as it's possible yes of course well as
long as it doesn't slow things down it's
we fair enough
um okay but but so and so as it doesn't
make the notebook jump which is another
issue
um I mean because what we don't want is
the thing you know it keeping on you
know it's running one map it's running
another table etcetera etcetera now what
I found like I've been doing lots of
parallel maps and I've been using this
parallel map monitored functionality in
the function repository very very useful
I mean I basically want that every time
I'm doing a parallel map by the time I'm
doing the parallel map it's going to
take significant time
if it wasn't then I wouldn't be doing a
parallel map it wouldn't be worth it um
so you know that's um you know that's
part of part of what um anyway so I mean
I think it's worthwhile so you you show
in here evaluating table I mean the
question is to what level are we going
to try to put progress indicators
because I would claim if you've got a
giant table I think it'd be very useful
that we progress indicators so long as
you can have enough of an indication of
what table we're talking about here bits
custom text I just put it there like you
can customize it I know yeah okay I mean
the idea is basically that the simple
panel is is something that like for
example you're doing a video map there's
you can either say like we are mapping
all the frames and progress bar or and
as the alternative is the other design
which is a kind of more informative
things when you when you want to give
extra information so which is the next
section the grid design but I think I
think there's a point here which is that
just like we have echo for instance
which is a very successful function um
right though we don't use it in system
functions right we use it to know to use
a level to use a level thing right but
what I'm imagining is that we could
imagine having a thing saying you know
show progress and then it's a piece of
code or something like that it would do
its best to show progress for that top
level function which might or might not
be possible it may or may not know how
to do it and it could be that show
progress will just say you know we'll
all it will say will be evaluating blah
blah blah and it won't be able to give a
percentage complete or anything like
that
by making sense well yeah I don't know
how practical that is I mean I think
it's probably better to add options or
have things automatically show their
progress that can show their progress
well but sometimes I know that this is
gonna be a long computation mm-hmm and
you know for me this will be very useful
I would I would just sprinkle it in to
coat just like I sprinkle and echo into
code and actually to be honest this
would be a you know it's like a
checkpoint of this is you know we
reached a particular point you know
we're entering this this code here it
just says what we're entering and you
know it knows when this is finished
right so it can say the thing that's
being enclosed here is being computed
and that will be very useful and then it
stays or it disappears is no it
disappears disappears that's a
possibility but it's literally in fact
that will be a very useful piece of
functionality it's just like I'm in this
code block and then you sprinkle it you
say whereas where's my code spending
time let me just wrap a show progress
around this and you know then I see oh
it's stuck in that code block I like
this idea okay but but so now all right
that but all right Jeremy Davis Jeremy
Davis is here Billy is here I mean we're
you know I would like to focus on the
visual aspect of progress in this
meeting
um yeah Steve livestream is saying that
show progress should go look at what
exper is and try and figure out how to
show the progress when it can I
completely agree with that and it will
you know there'll be some things where
it does a better job than others and
some it will just say all I know is that
we just went into this function okay
okay so let's take a look at visually
what we're talking about here Ethan our
live stream is saying please add ETA s
by default um yes I mean that's an
interesting I know that for look I'll
just show you this function of parallel
map monitored I mean let me comment on
two things about this okay so let's look
at parallel map monitored um
Wow okay it's better to actually see it
running never mind okay so let's let's
just do well you'll see a bunch of
things happening here probably like the
initial the rather horrifying um I can I
go I can say pause of five or something
um actually no that's not going to work
I should say parallel map monitored so I
need to do that um house a little bit
funky mapped across range of a thousand
or something anything isn't oh oh oh oh
oh my gosh silly me
thank you there we go okay so this under
whites okay so there so that gives an
ETA and I like that you see when you
heard that the time thing there's a
lapse time remaini time so we we
typically do that but that's not an ETA
that's remaining time that's different
from an ETA the issue is two people want
an ETA I mean for me okay
seeing the ETA is somewhat useful like I
see oh it's gonna be ten minutes it's
gonna be done at 2:30 or something as
opposed it's gonna be done in five
minutes
that's the difference I'm not sure if
it's a good thing yeah I'm my instinct
is that I would rather have the time
remaining I mean usually when I see an
ETA it's like oh okay well what's the
current time how much how much into the
future it's that yeah actually multiple
people on a live stream supporting the
idea of an ETA I mean you know look for
gps's I remember early gps's
said time to destination that was their
primary thing later GPS is almost always
say ETA
um I mean it's in that case at least
it's I mean you know if it's like is
this gonna be done before my next
meeting starts type things mm-hmm but
both the useful okay both these you can
have as many keys he's not useful for
seconds right or even sure no absolutely
only ones only useful when it's in in
the minutes or you know or hours yeah
it's also only useful when it's fairly
accurate um okay
all right so what the things at the top
you were you were just this was just for
orientation or what yes what we
currently have these these all so these
graphical element I would we have
already and all the new graphical
element so you're gonna see our proposal
just to understand these these have not
been installed in all the places they're
supposed to be installed without true
statement install in some places and
there's a list at the bottom of the
notebook of places where they have been
installed okay fine fine
and and another question the places
where there are existing progress
monitors which don't follow these
patterns are those known yes yes and
part of the reason for this new grid
panel is to encompass some of those like
the neural neural network or the machine
learning functions that okay so this one
and definitely by the time you're doing
this level of detail you should have an
ETA here um okay so what are we really
looking at what's the console what is
all this stuff
help oh I see this is this is the thing
for the command-line right
it's this implemented now is this what
this is doing is this using some curse
of weird cursive control to go back and
you know in its time machine go back and
add things here yes and and and that's
why we need and actually a so
Constantine just added something to the
prototype last night so that we we we
may have be able to push this out
further than
but you know right now we have to sort
of working on common UNIX terminals but
there are still some unsolved problems
is there and it's still on etc term cap
out and about in the world from like
1980 or something yep
although it's probably mostly term info
these days or rather yeah so my Linux
box has the term info but not the term
cap okay so this thing here evaluate
with progress that is the internal API
that's the internal function for doing
this is that correct yes yes and that
has all of this detail about what it's
actually going to show yep
it has two syntaxes right now I mean we
don't want to linger too much on the
syntax but the the panel thing is
constrained and it will do certain
things based on the specific keys that
you use while the grid is freeform and
you can put whatever you want into that
okay okay um right so we had some
questions about the the grid above which
I well I mean are we ready
should I be scrolling down and looking
at no you should be scrolling up okay
just tell me what to do
so right so open the the static section
that's in prototype right so this is I
guess a version where we're headed
towards okay so one question is the
title right you're explaining what thing
is somehow right whereas in these are
you what is our pattern for explaining
that I mean this is when you're saying
importing or computing computing is just
a key that is displayed if you don't put
any text if you fill in the text key you
will have so in terms of usage it seems
to me if there is something right there
on the input line of the repple like
import blah blah blah saying to people
oh your import is taking whatever is
kind of silly right on the other hand if
the import was deep inside a piece of
code you've got to tell them what it is
that's messaging you you know what it is
that you're showing progress about
so to my mind there are actually two
different cases and that goes along with
this sort of show progress wrapper where
it's like okay in other words what I'm
saying is if it's that if it's right
there at the top level I don't think you
have to explain what it is that's giving
you the progress information but if it
is deeply nested you do need to have
some kind of head of saying what it is
that's giving right but import doesn't
know whether it's at the top level or
whether it's well I only sign whatever
the displayer right but import is the
displayer right when you import certain
kinds of slow things and automatically
puts these up right that was the whole
point of this project well okay I
understand that I'm asking the question
can it know if it's at the top level I
know I understand that it can't know but
maybe something in the chain of dead
that does the display can know I mean
for example at the very trivial level
mm-hmm I mean look there are ways it
could know by by it sending back a hash
of itself and being compared with a
thing that is looking from the top at
the you know when it's actually giving
the final display how important do we
think it is UX wise the thing I'm just
describing I mean I would hate it I mean
go ahead well what do you think well
right but it normally doesn't say
importing right it says like preparing
you know right it's giulio can you give
a video example off the top of your head
if you export the video it says like
pre-processing video frames and then
writing video frames the video frames
are written okay fine but because that
function is probably one of the ones
that it's your sort of top function it's
in you know you know what it's doing but
if that was part of some giant workflow
yeah we have a point
absolutely discussion point about this
which is the last one which is a
multi-step computations and yet we also
want a design for that actually that's
it that's it
I don't know if you want to discuss it
now we can it's kind of well I'm
responding to it whose question about
does it have a giant header that says my
computation or does it have no header at
all see what I'm saying yeah this is a
design that that currently easy I know I
know I know I know I know so I'm
[Music]
describing when do we think we want a
big header and when do we know what so
so what do we so why don't we open up
like like classify right classify is one
of the guys that well you know as in the
ref page for classifying okay right so
what what does it currently do if we
evaluate one of those examples classify
play progress I'm not that keen on that
I'm not that keen on the way that header
looks either right that header is like
like you know that header is good if
it's like you didn't know classify was
going to be called I'm telling you big
story this is classified that's running
right as opposed to of course I know
classifies what's going on because the
only thing I typed in in which makes
kind of stupid looking that it's got a
big kind of a very well point out that
technically it's not the only thing you
typed in because set is the top-level
head of the input expression um right so
so exactly what you mean by I am the
topmost thing is a little bit obscure I
don't know but I think that there are
heuristics that I can imagine and I mean
you know the whole point of this is so
okay let me just mention one computable
issue here okay I I do think
that something we need to work towards
as the symbolic logging framework where
we're capable of writing anything that
is being written as a message out to the
screen is also be capable of being
logged for batch jobs so it's worth
bearing that in mind and we might very
well want to checkpoint some of these
you know messages say in computing forty
percent fifty percent whatever because
if you're running a batch job and it ran
for six hours it's really useful to you
to know that it got to sixty percent and
then crashed does that makes any sense
yes so I mean just bearing that in mind
okay so so coming back over here alright
so I get it but there's a I mean this is
a big header situation with classify as
opposed to import which I think has no
big headers it just says video yep so I
mean like like let's do this for video
for example if I go to video and what
would I do I would take take the example
video for example and what would I what
would I do with this I would say export
it to something punch it right on my
disk but I'll export it to a temporary
file that's probably a mistake I'll
probably just use create file which will
create the file without opening it and
then yeah okay so now what I do as I say
export that video to this create file I
wouldn't even know what the file is um
that gonna work well do you need oh you
might need to give it a format since it
doesn't have you write in oh okay give
me a format
okay so if this was I mean that's nice
that's good an ETA would be nice here
um I mean that looks pretty nice what
what that is doing there um in a sense
what that's doing is it's implicitly
telling me this is a video right so if
the classifier said you know computing
classification or something like that
I'm implicitly being told that rather
than having this great big you know
you've got a big title header there no
making sense yeah what the head there is
basically the current like I just took
the code so this might be an alternative
thing here that has less I just don't
think we need that big goon thing there
but also we need to know whether this is
going to be a dot dot dot type thing
which I think it should be and this is
just an additional information panel
what's that grade I mean that's a later
point ignore it for the time being sorry
we have a single mock-up for multiple
things but yeah okay fine
so what are we supposed to be looking at
here so what we're what I'm saying I
think is what we want visually is the
same kind of wording of you know
computing bla bla bla bla
mm-hmm and maybe some of those will even
have their summary elapsed time double
double blah and then underneath is a
panel with more detail that makes sense
yeah and do we want that always open
because I know with more detail yes in
this case which case like this one that
you're looking at right collapse an
extended are the same panel in two
different states well I don't like I
think that this needs to be a little bit
more explicit than this I mean you know
I think it should have a more something
word because it wasn't obvious what this
was I mean in terms
is it the case that we can save I mean
that it is more efficient we're not then
generating a bunch of the the kind of
telemetry is that correct I mean if the
plot can be arbitrarily complex to draw
right it won't want to draw it you save
up some time I mean I think yes I think
it's useful to have the ability to close
up I mean depending on what one's
looking at you know it could be that you
don't I mean generally my opinion is
people want to see this progress
information okay if you're sitting there
and your screen is you know and and
nothing's happening for five minutes
much better that you see the progress
than not I can't see why people would
close it um but I mean I suppose we
could have something that closes the
whole progress thing I what's the reason
why people might close the progress
thing I mean I'm having a hard time
coming up with a reason the only reason
is I mean as long as like the the single
line of the overall progress is in there
they'd might just want something a bit
less noisy on their screen but I don't
know that it's super essential this was
something people used to noisy crud on
their screens from using the web I don't
know the closure thing I it's not clear
to me oh yeah given that maybe it's
better to have a complete close button
for the whole progress indicator like
for whatever reason somebody doesn't
want to see progress and I don't quite
know why but maybe maybe there's a case
of that maybe somebody on the livestream
might want to comment on that um well
that would be at another button so that
that's interesting that's I don't think
a button we considered right um okay
okay so I think we have what we need
here we you like this overall design we
don't need a collapse er necessarily
right okay so buttons so there's a
question from Ethan our livestream about
themes for this and one of the questions
is fitting into different style sheets
of notebooks I'm
dock mode and all that kind of stuff so
the class so the short answer is we
certainly have no support for things at
the moment I'm not sure and the current
state of the code I don't think it would
be super easy to add which isn't to say
that I'm opposed to adding that support
it's just you know I have a simple
question from the notebook style sheet
what flows through to these progress
boxes is is it defined in a style and in
the overall style sheet it's it's
defined by a style in chord and B
because I all right I think we're using
that in patches here isn't that right no
not really I'm using some code that
design gave to tally for the first
iteration of this is actually hard-coded
but for the first version we already
decided that we are gonna move to front
right so we could right so I guess these
styles are are are they're just color
directives then they're not things like
nine patches or to them so that means it
could be handled in a style sheet and
it's just a named style and if somebody
makes the dark mode style sheet they can
just change the name style for progress
boxes or something right um okay
oh that's a good point from Brian here
doing a demo or a screen recording you
might not want the progress indicator
that is a good example yes that is a
good example
we disabled it for the function they're
gonna use it right so we I concern about
that is that you might not know and
there might be functions which don't
bring it up until they've been running
for fifteen seconds or something and
then suddenly in the middle of your demo
it pops up with this thing so I mean
there's an argument just like we're
talking about show progress there's an
argument for a quiet-like mechanism that
just says don't show progress in this
whole you know switch off progress for
this whole area right well I think if we
if we just made the default
value of this option to be you know
dollar progress reporting or whatever
then you could set that to false yes I
mean it could also want it imagine it as
a style sheet option for the notebook mm
you could it would be a little funky
right because then the evaluation would
have to somehow know what notebook it's
in and consult that notebook right I
want to ask question which self is also
asking on the live stream about about
some the thing moving your notebook view
when the progress indicator comes up
does it come up once and not change the
size or what happens when in presumably
the progress indicator doesn't come up
for the first five seconds or something
it's two seconds okay but so as a
practical matter you know I'm typing
something I've got my thing I'm typing
in the next cell and then the thing
comes up because it moved down where I'm
typing it does doesn't it
what does what does it move down me okay
so what I'm saying is if I'm typing okay
so so this is a front-end question right
if I'm typing somewhere and a progress
indicator comes up above me okay does it
move me down or does the notebooks does
the content of the notebook push upwards
I see so so you're asking does the which
way does the viewport move yes not not
about keyboard focus but about the the
viewport no I'm assuming we're not you
know if we lost keyboard focus we'd be
dead in the water well I'm assuming we
do not lose keyboard focus I think the
principle is that the front end should
go to somewhat great lens to make sure
that your insertion cursor while you're
typing stays where it is on your screen
and if the notebook needs to reflow
around it then it reflows around it
leaving it but so then what you'd see is
the the content at the top of the
notebook would move up to make room for
the progress indicator that arrived
above your typing that's what I claimed
the principal should be I don't know
what the current behavior
if you if if you can get stuff in the
charts Stephen but if you try which is
kind of then tell me at least my front
end it moves out okay so I do that
and now what I'm doing this oh wait a
minute that moved down as I was acting
it didn't be all right I mean I have to
say I have not found this deeply
annoying at this point
so specifically upper brain I guess
right I mean okay okay so Sandra is
asking what would only see one dialogue
at a time I think no you might see
several because it might be nested yes
and this is the chain evaluation section
that we had so there are a few few
possibilities for this and I personally
think you've got to show them when it
nests you gotta show the alternative is
what we have like the first alternative
is there like we we kind of if you know
in advance like for example if you're
writing a function and you know that
there are multiple progress indicators
you can actually give this information
and they would be collected the
alternative design is the last one where
you kind of whenever you have a nested
indicator you are you don't know in
advance but you attach it or there's the
easiest to implement which is each one
just pops into an existence and pops out
on its own unless you go to the trouble
of somehow combining them I mean
personally I'm not that I'm not an
unhappy about that I think there's too
much visual space between them here but
I think in terms of
you know in the case where you again it
generating a giant stack I mean it
depends on how chatty things become but
at least right now when he's a fairly
sparse it doesn't seem problematic to
stack him like that you can reprint on
the same one if you want it sits among
the possibilities of the other utility
so if you know that you are doing
different things you can like like what
video is doing is updating the text so
that's what it should do when it's
within one function it should stick
within one of these boxes but the
problem is if one function calls another
function simply because I don't know
you're doing file system scan and each
you know the file system scan has one of
these it's saying it's scanning over a
thousand files but each individual file
you get - you're doing a different thing
to it yeah or you could have like what
karna was suggesting once was at every
system function basically prints in the
same container so each each time there's
a new ID to replace the old one and then
just go like give that control it's done
the alternative is to print all of them
and another alternative is that the
outer one is kind of paying attention
and when when an inner one kicks in it
will it will add the step thing or
something like that I think that's going
to complicated and I think it's gonna
get tangled up I think just just having
them be separate making this I think I
mean I think I I don't think this
aggregation I think this could be super
confusing whereas this is fairly clear
what's going on the only issue is if you
see something that says loading data
loading data loading data which data are
you loading what are you talking about
well we need a style for what those
things say but the problem is what
your mapping or worse during a parallel
map across multiple let's just talk
about parallel stuff for a second okay
they've been a bunch of comments on a
live stream about parallel um are we
going to be able to bring back progress
indicators from parallel kernels that's
first question I'm not sure that's going
to be tricky a we certainly don't have
anything for that now well I mean what
we have right now is the is let's see we
have the parallel kernel status dialog
right which is just this thing which is
a little bit rickety in some ways why is
it not okay see I don't know this is
some weird dynamic thing it scares me to
have it even open I mean that's
something we have I mean that's for
pretty heavyweight use of parallel
kernels right but it's not telling you
anything
I mean it's telling you sort of if
they're in use or not but it's not
telling you it's not getting any data
sort of directly out of there out of
those sub kernels and right there isn't
what your timing things right but it's
not right it's not right if you have a
variable X that's being evaluated in
that sub kernel that information is not
here absolutely right right this is all
sort of information that's readily
accessible to the master kernel and the
problem is right these are dynamics
which means they're communications
between the kernel and the front end and
there isn't an obvious way for the sub
kernel to communicate with the front end
right it doesn't have that link so well
I mean to be honest if we actually
really really cared about this we could
use you know we could use for example
the channel framework to do this we
could have the sub kernel throw a
message you know the same way we do it
for our web infrastructure
um although that's using a slightly
different system but we could throw it
you know we could throw these messages
out into into the channel system mm-hmm
I want to say this is related to echo
from parallel kernels and Roman plans on
adding a variable that would determine
whether the parent kernel came from a
notebook session so that well that's
nice but but but what's he gonna do with
it how's he gonna get the information
package he's sending it back over the SS
tp-link or what I don't know but the
goal is to be able to sell print the
nice echo cells even from a sub kernel
fair enough well that's good but I
suggest looking at the tunnel framework
as a possible way to do this I think
it's a robust way to do it um rather
than sending it back on the WS tp-link
with all kinds of weird back-and-forth
stuff going on um okay now let's see I'm
just um Steve was saying on the live
stream
don't make don't make the mistake that
Netscape made back in the day where it's
ETA goes from zero to 25 minutes to
infinity to zero to whatever yes that's
an issue and of course I mean I think um
you know there's a certain homogeneity
assumption that's being made like that
parallel map monitor does surprisingly
well you know even when there is some in
homogeneity in the in the computation
times that actually know how it works
it's a Max ISKCON off production of some
kind
um don't know what he exactly did but it
seems to work quite well I don't know
what we're what are we doing for the
time remaining how are we computing that
I mean there are those cases where we
readily know that it is some fraction
complete and so on I mean you need to
specify some so some form of progress
are there you give a progress key or you
say you know that I have a total byte
count and a current byte count something
like that and then we internally the
indicator keeps its best estimate of the
current
over me you know you know the I say you
know the time that has elapsed and it
gives the current best estimate of the
total time that it will take based on
the on the progress and that is updated
whenever something changes history its
given example if you're factoring
integers or something and you make a
table it is the case that the later
integers in the table will take longer
to factor but we would not detect that
probably with our current technology
well no but I mean the alternative would
be some simple machine learning thing to
look at because that's a I mean to me
that would be a comparatively common
case that there's a loop and things are
getting systematically let's say more
difficult like that oh yeah we could fit
the distribution yes
why not do that I mean if it's cheap to
do it would not as well do it and get a
better estimate I mean right now what I
have now is just moving moving average
but I I confess I just did some
optimization at the beginning and then
back to that but for the final thing
especially when is user facing then we
can provide like more fancy estimation
um Ethan is asking please add monitoring
for parallel downloading I see that the
the data the transfer of data to
parallel kernels yeah I've noticed that
that doesn't show anything is that
something we can do I I don't see why we
shouldn't be able to do that did you
understand the issue of kernel
communication okay so what happens is in
you know you're doing a parallel
computation you're getting results
they're coming back to the main kernel
you probably know in the WS TP transfer
you probably know how what the total
transfer size is but it just doesn't
hasn't arrived yet you get what I'm
saying oh but the protocol needs a
callback or something
well I think the protocol has a bunch of
those things I don't I mean I don't
think that WS t PE I mean we're talking
milliseconds right so there would not no
we're not I've often been waiting for
five minutes for that because it could
be because it's a remote kernel I mean
there's just
well it there just can't be that much
data right the the front-end and kernel
right you transfer you know two hundred
Meg's right and that that we're talking
you know milliseconds maybe seconds I
just don't believe that W STP can be
that slow on on a local machine now if
you're tough
it's H fast local connections well okay
I don't know exactly maybe people on the
live stream can comment on their
experience there Ethan particularly is
talking about parallel downloading I
mean ah I think that's been taking time
but but on my machine but who knows it
might be something else that was taking
time
um so question here there was a
suggestion here about nested indicators
seeing the top-level sum of all the
child indicators the problem with that
is I don't think do we know that
computer plea like in other words yeah
these we give it a lot of thought
actually and the the the big problem is
if you are responsible for the whole
pipeline you can be fancy if you like
these indicators maybe like if I use a
builds up a function with indicators
then it might not be possible to know
what will happen next and let's say that
I have an if and if it fires depending
on the input I download something so I
understand that but the question here
was if if each indicator exposed it's
you know time expect you know ETA or
something like that
actually even that's really hard but if
you could document in principle at least
that contains all the remaining times
and you could sum it if you want no but
that's not right it's not right because
things are nested within each other it's
not right it's the same as you with
profiling right in other words it will
be incorrect to take the sum of all the
times of all those pieces and say that's
the total time it's going to take that
will be completely wrong right I don't
think it can be done I don't think
there's a way to give an aggregate time
even if we knew it even if we could
compute ibly expose it from each of the
progress indicators um okay all right so
what's the question here so I think
we're saying just have these be separate
and nest as they nest so to speak and
don't try to be good over here
okay so we need to go up you because you
skipped over buttons and that's a big
question
okay right so right so an abort button
is something we can always give right
because that's just command dot you know
I suppose there can be badly behaved
code that doesn't respond to interrupts
but that you know that's a bug that can
be dealt with right then now some of the
machine learning functions have this
stop button which you know say stop the
training now and return what you have
stopped and returned right basically but
you know we definitely need special
support for that in the underlying code
it's super useful when we can do it
mm-hmm right and so the question is
should we always have them should we
have one and then the other should we
only have the stop when it's available
should we have one that sort of can be
one or the other I don't use right now I
mean right now I've been pretty happy
with the way the stop works
to the machine learning stuff where is
it in fact right now it's big but that
but Dad that's because they have special
support for it
right so they they can opt into it I
understand I'm just talking pretty early
where it is just just say see time goal
like 10 or 20 so they progress it will
train for bedtime and you can see the
indicator for a while you say yeah I'm
going to tap 20 say okay well that's
very obvious what that does it doesn't
make me think it's going to abort it
mm-hmm which is a bit unfortunate
because the their progress indicator is
intercepting aborts so if you press
command period you're gonna see the same
thing which I'm not super happy about
yeah I think that that is a bug that we
were in with it
so you could press come on period
nothing runny to gain an aborted with
I see so that did a stop basically
exactly there's a checker board which is
redirecting the abort command to similar
results of pressing mr. button why is
that bad I mean wouldn't it be beautiful
functions would just let you abort them
I mean I guess that what happens if it
was nested inside something else well
the abort will be a bit what we caught
and then not propagate to the other
things as well exactly yeah exactly
um well that's a problem it's a
different semantics I don't understand
why you know every computation one's
doing shouldn't be bringing up you know
if the computation is running for a long
time there should be some UX I mean in
the cloud isn't there UX that brings up
an abort button if the computation is
running for a long time it's in the
header bar isn't it very well there
there's an important it's but not a stop
button no I understand that I understand
it I'm saying I think that the abort
button should be nothing to do with the
progress dialogues because I think
particularly in a situation where you
have five nested progress dialogues and
they've all got aborts all the aborts do
the same thing it's gonna be super
confusing I think abort should not be
part of this okay and I think that the
abort I think what is the case is that
there should be probably in the new
standardized notebook toolbar there
should be an abort thing that's offered
to you if your computation took more
than a certain number of seconds Sewer
since I think that's how we should
handle abort I strongly think that
shouldn't be part of this and I I think
so basically we either have no button or
a stop button if the function has opted
into offering that yes but the question
is where does the stop button go and I
think I mean it will be a minority of
functions that have the stop possibility
yep
I mean in a sense it's it's returned
partial results stop and return I mean
does it make more sense as an accept
button no way nobody will understand
what that means no I think I mean right
word but I think it might need something
you know stop and return or somesuch
other thing mm-hmm I mean it might stop
and not ever if I if the function is
just the changes some variable I'm not
sure we can make the assumption they
return something what do you mean if the
function is stable and it stopped the
devil won't offer that this button only
thing set up into it will will offer
this button sure say I write my function
my table that does or my function
whatever that just modifies the value of
variable that doesn't necessarily return
anything right just has a side effect I
see what's the point you're making that
there's a side effect that we I'm not
sure we can make the assumption that
pressing stop will attempt something
well it will return yes I guess that's
rude but it will return whatever it
wouldn't right but it would still return
the same thing it would have returned
had you've gotten to the years yes
correct so right so we could call it you
know I mean we could call it stop and
use current or yeah that's a bit verbose
but or stop and use current results it's
a bit verbose but it would be clear and
if we only I mean if if we want to keep
it at the bottom like like we've had it
up till now we would certainly have the
room for some
verbose like that well so your point is
right now the stops that we have are all
side-effect list stops we will know if
they're side effect list well I mean
obviously you could put in machine
learning thing who put something which
it for an option it's monitoring
function could have some weird side
effect but we'll assume that if you do
that it's kind of up to you um so the
issue is I mean which functions are
actually gonna have a stop button now
initially the one we're talking about
the machine learning functions because
they're the only ones which have really
implemented this functionality you know
I'll do my live stream is complaining
about the internationalization of the
word to stop but I have to say I have
seen signs that are octagonal red signs
that have the word stop on them in
places all over the world so I have to
believe of all the different English
phrases that might be understood that's
one of the better ones particularly if
we hadn't all you know a.m. if we want
if we had anything octagonal there we're
we're very clear I claim the I do some
experiments with Robin Oliver in the
early early stopping PD integration
where for example you want to in nd
solve for ten seconds and when you stop
you get the first five seconds yes
that's mean that's already doable okay
so that's the next thing that might be
coming after me I mean I can imagine
optimization code where you can you know
the you get better you refine more route
finding you were fine more as you can we
early stop a video export transcoding
and just have a short video I am not
sure that that is possible at the moment
nobody in principle is
because I think it depends on the codec
right some codecs
well I mean it'll still be usable if you
just end the frames and other codecs
will be like a you know this is not this
is a corrupt file yes I mean if we if we
if we use something that makes sure to
finalize the right that should be
possible I mean because this is not an
abort stop let me ask a visual question
okay if that was an octagon but people
know what it was without words
if it were a wreck if there were a red
octagon I think they would I'm not sure
if if we're a blue octagon they would
know and we do use the square for
audio-video that's not an uncommon
symbol for stop I don't think it's yes
but it's a strong gun fair enough but
that's a stop where you're pausing and
you can restart right a stop and video
is a stop that can be restarted this is
not that I mean gosh really wait yeah go
ahead
we don't really have a stop for audio
and video we just have the concept of
pause there however in audio captured
there is a stop button that had the
function exactly this you press it and
it returns something let's look at that
for a sec yeah I mean that was a super
confusing thing for ages the way audio
capture was getting cleaned always it
has been cleaned up but yeah
okay so now right now this is just
giving me the opportunity to capture
right right by the way why did this not
expand in size when I did a 150% oh this
is being fixed right now we are
switching to vector assets so the
magnification will work so I'm now
recording hello hello hello and then
that means stop and return so that
iconography meant oh um okay so that
iconography that we had there
so that means ready to record that means
that icon there is stop and return
mm-hmm not the silliest icon for stop
and return I mean yeah if once saw that
icon over here I kind of think one would
have an I think one would have an idea
what that meant right and and you know I
I would argue first of all I think
that's a reasonable one and second of
all unlike a board which throws away
everything you've done right these will
save results so it's not catastrophic if
you know people will be catastrophic or
you spent two hours doing training and
then you press that button and you lose
everything else you were doing but
you're not losing everything else you
were doing right that's the whole point
of this button if it were an abort
button it would be catastrophic but the
stop button right and you can always
resume the training you can in fact
resume the training right you can take
that data and doesn't refine it
yes that's correct this indicator panel
is gone by that time you will not see as
soon as you press this button the
indicator pattern well this panel will
disappear that's a close button for the
indicator panel and for the computation
mm-hmm okay so what we have on the table
is see again it depends a lot on whether
you're gonna see this as the only thing
you're seeing on your screen possibly
with a very heavy weight you know
display like the thing we were seeing
over here well you know this is a giant
heavy weight display and having a big
stop button there
seems you know
um still not great I mean you know I
didn't understand I mean I I had to
actually try this to know that this
meant stop and return partial results
going to do this I would say you know a
stop button and then say stop paren and
return partial results there's a tooltip
I mean that would be enough for me
up at the tooltip okay return partial
results yes yes the tooltip says stop
and return partial results well now the
question is for a big panel like that
having a stop button is fine
for something like this where it's a
minimized panel I would think that
having that circle in a you know with a
square inside it would be reasonable
with a dual tooltip same tooltip I think
that works okay fine I mean we could
repeat the iconography by having that
icon as part of the button that says
stop yeah okay um okay fine we got it we
got a plan there everybody happy with
that yep buttons okay good all right
what else do we have to figure out here
all right so this is just sort of
talking about what we need still need to
do so I you know obviously we need to
implement the decisions we made today
but I think this is all except maybe for
that last point I think we this is all
pretty straightforward what is this the
correct evaluation self cannot be
triggered from a target is when you have
these indicators you wanna specially
when you have a delay you want to be
super efficient because the idea is if
the competition is gonna be short and
you don't know in advance like a very
fast export you don't want any overhead
at all and but if it is long you want to
actually print the indicator just
underneath the cell which is doing that
comments on a live stream from Brian who
suggests the phrasing end now are
complete now isn't gonna work because
you don't know whether that's a noun or
verb adjective or a verb but end now as
opposed to stop it's sort of interesting
look I think stop and return as a
tooltip is probably the better solution
I worry that end now it's again you
don't know whether that's a description
or a command it is the end
um
go ahead I'm sorry I distracted from a
scheduled posture discussion yes so so
let me let me back up Julio's
explanation a bit which is suppose you
you rather than evaluating a single cell
you select the you know a whole section
and evaluate seven input cells at once
then the normal print temporary rather
well will trigger at the bottom of the
last input cell selected rather than the
currently evaluating cell is is that the
correct description I mean depends what
you call print temporary print temporary
does the right thing
the problem is that we don't want to do
it immediately we want to delay it if we
print immediately we don't have this
problem
oh you've got a stack of cells you say
to evaluate all of them and the question
is when the temporary display starts
coming up where does it come up does it
come under the exactly right so it comes
out of there under the currently
evaluating cell rather than the cell
that created the the progress panel what
do you have like five five cells you run
like pose five post five post five and
one in the middle has a progress
indicator so the point is that Google's
indicator can appear immediately or can
appear after a little time how do I make
the progress indicator kind of
suggesting that this should be a user
level thing what what's the context for
valuators progress progress backtick
kind of suggest this should be leaves a
level thing but anyway it's the final
point of the to-do list okay we need to
sort out details first so the point is
like do that and then create another
post five below you just need one and
you can have another post five below
that and then it'll read them together
you're saying
well I'm gonna just confuse it even more
I'm gonna put a second one of those in
yeah all right so now you said I select
all of these is that so
there's immediate no wait this is this
is solvable and and I know how to solve
it because you can track whatever cell
start at the evaluation the point is
it's not free it has a considerable
overhead which I don't know Sean is
going to kill me if I make export a fast
export take 0.2 seconds more because i
need to ask the front end in which cell
it's starting so I mean the solution is
not efficient okay you're asking an
engineering question I bet there are
other solutions maybe something with the
channel framework maybe something with
some I mean you've got to pass back
information basically to the front well
we first need to firm no no no the
problem isn't passing back the
information the PAS problem is gathering
the information when you might not need
it I understand that's what it needs to
be okay the question is which the seller
is evaluating doesn't the front end know
that internally and you start gathering
after the delay the inferno knows it yes
the friend knows it while you're
evaluating you look on yes you pose that
with a current value for example well
anything that requires a front end
callback is going to have some overhead
I think the the only suggestion that
I've heard that I liked was from
Constantine in a and I think our last
meeting maybe two meetings ago where he
suggested the front end send it as part
of the bulk of information that it sends
with each evaluation so the colonel has
always kept up-to-date with what the
current evaluation cell is but of course
that requires changes to the front end
colonel contract that would be
implemented at some low level well I
think that's the thing to think about I
mean that it would just send the ID of
the cell I mean isn't right isn't there
gonna be a USL UUID couldn't it send the
side that that's useful right that that
is effectively the cell object in the
whole cell object just has to send the
the cell object is is in probably going
to be the symbol cell object wrapped
around a UUID so that is the whole cell
object I see I personally support the
idea of sending that to the colonel and
yeah I think that will have other uses
that have nothing to do with this
I put likely yep and I think it's
something where the you know there
should be a variable
perhaps the current value variable
perhaps something else that is the you
know currently evaluating so you write
that can already be obtained the
difficulty here is because of the
because of the schedule task that's
involved with how we're delaying this
progress that we've missed the window
that we can ask for the evaluation cell
okay fine so it's got to be sent to
preemptively
yep okay um like this is only okay
switch to the terminal
okay all right Wow
really okay okay fine
so is only we need to say about the
about the terminal window stuff the
things we've talked about here like for
example the stop button is that is it
gonna say you know tight period to stop
or something
how's it gonna have the stop button that
is a good question which I don't think
we have an answer for I think you should
says pressed period to stop or some such
other thing i mean III whether you want
it to be a command key or whether you
just want it to be um if you can
intercept keys
yeah because I don't know that we can I
don't know that we can intercept these
while an evaluation is in progress
other other than other attendees other
than that yes other than the board and
interrupt and I guess control see which
is I mean you can what you certainly can
do
I mean amusingly SMP did this back in
1979 or something you you you know in at
least in UNIX right you can you can
press control-c and you can bring up up
you know you can bring up a line that
says press a to abort you know Q to quit
etc right and and yes and the question
is can we can we hijack that or can we
I'm right but that's the question is can
somebody other than you know me and
Constantine going in and writing C code
that do that I'd rather not do that
publicity code to do it but but that's
okay but fine let go investigate that
but I think we need a solution for how
to deal with the stop button on terminal
okay kernel propagation right so these
are ones where they've already you know
are using right so to me the user facing
function I don't know what the
relationship between the show progress
wrapper for an individual for an
individual thing and the evaluate with
progress I think there's really the
evaluate with progress I see is a user
defined thing where you give it some
callbacks and so on right right so the
evaluate progress is what we need people
to integrate progress indicators into
automatic progress indicators into their
own functions right which is different
from show progress which is take this
arbitrary expression and do something
guess what you can do with it
I understand both being useful yes right
okay those are just links you don't okay
so we're pretty much done here and we've
got another live stream actually coming
up for LCC which also involves some of
the same people
yep they're starring the same cast of
characters partly um okay they've met
okay Ethan is just asking about pours
continue I believe that I do not think
that's worthwhile to these things we
have here yeah yeah the only right so I
mean the only thing we can offer without
major engineering resources as entering
dialogue and I'm not sure we want to go
that route I see where you could
potentially see what's going on because
that's the only case I mean if you can't
see what's going on pause continue is
useless rate would entering a dialogue
work or will it will it be bizarre
because things are left in an unfinished
States and so on it is a purely kernel
operation then yes if it is a library
operation then it depends IP is a
library supporting stopper resume like
post a resume otherwise if you're
launching an external I believe she does
download the download can probably go
ahead even if so if it is a puny current
thing if I did some experiments and is
kind of working mmm
the usefulness I mean so that would be
another thing associated with the stop
button would be an additional button
that's some kind of inspection button
yeah right
but then right people would need to know
to call returned to or we'd need to
provide another way we can put that we
put that in the I mean what would it do
it would bring up a dialog no sub
notebook basically I mean it's in within
that notebook it would bring up the kind
of the dialogue a newly headed piece of
notebook that is the dialogue correct no
no it's the criminal entering dialogue
right it's so it's the same as what does
it command the option period the right
if you do pause of five yeah just
evaluating dialogue right what did that
just do help you and then you can just
type other things and you're in a sub
colonel yeah I think yeah so now just
happened here I mean oh I see that's us
that's some kind of fuzzy line there
yeah yeah no and they send it but this
is utterly unclear if I might say so I
mean this is this was this was probably
good in the in you know one when this
was the only thing we could do but this
has got to be a lot chattier yeah so
like it should have some temporary cell
there until you start typing at least
and now bizarrely I type return bizarre
what did it do in the text terminal you
add a few more spaces before the okay so
this is pretty cruddy I mean this this
to me yeah I mean this is something that
has not been refreshed in in 25 years at
least
right so else and I wasn't I wasn't
convinced this you so I think if we want
even if we wanted to do this we need to
invest in yeah this is for the future
this is not for version one of the
progress indicator stuff and to my mind
the you know if we were to do this we
would have to indicate how to get you
know when you enter the dialog we would
have to have some material there that
says you know this is the
what am I trying to say that that um um
you know that tells you things about how
you can interrogate this computation all
right we should wrap up here I'm gonna
go straight to the LCC livestream
so those watching we're going to switch
to a different channel but we'll be back
in a moment and thank you to people
working on this project and to people
who are commenting see all a moment Hey
bye